hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on borderlines 3 again
today we have some information to talk
about the malla wanna take down black
site mission as well as dlc one and a
few big patches coming to the game very
very shortly so as long as like them if
you're doing dress subscribe before new
that's not waste any more time and let's
get started so first up we're gonna talk
about the main patches and the very
first thing I'm gonna be mentioning is
bank space increase the bank space is
getting increased six times more so
instead of having the current 50 we're
gonna have 300 they didn't state that
you may have to buy SD use to get it
higher it might just be the highest one
you get at the legendary tier might be
30 as opposed to 50 so that's incredible
I'm not sure how that's gonna work but
either way the highest amount of guns
you can carry per character or in the
safe and stuff is gonna be 300 on top of
that most if not all legendaries will
have a specific drop instead of just the
general loophole so that requires us to
go back to the borderlands 2 days and
farm specific bosses and not just
gravelord for a week straight like a lot
of us have been doing navigating the
menu is no longer gonna be annoying and
laggy so Amara means rejoice for this so
constantly going into the menu and
switching elements will not be a pain
anymore it will be a lot faster and
they're gonna change the UI just a
little bit to conform with all these you
know the space the timing and the format
as well mayhem for is gonna be
introduced we knew a lot about this
mayhem for and mayhem 2.0 and Thapa so
they actually stated a little bit about
what that's going to be for mayhem for
gearbox said they're going to be
removing all negatives to players and
only having one stat that's positive for
you and one positive for the enemies
technically that you know one positive
for the enemies also means a negative
towards you but it's actually a lot
better and it'll make a lot more sense
when it comes out in the full game and
as well there's going to be an overhaul
coming to mayhem called mayhem 2.0
coming in 2020 so expect mayhem for to
come up before the year is over and
mayhem 2.0 to come in 2020 very early
within the year and then the last thing
for the big patches that they're going
to be adding is more vending machines
now nothing new nothing crazy it's gonna
be the same ammo health and guns of any
machines that were used to but there's
going to be a lot more spread throughout
the map the one I'm hoping specifically
gets this change is a thenis if you've
been an Athena cyou understand
there is one in the very beginning and
there is not a single one later so if
you're trying to farm truant it is an
absolute [ __ ] because you have to get
ammo from all this stuff and nearby
because there's no vending machines
anywhere
so hopefully that gets added and
hopefully they had a lot more and Athena
specifically because it is an absolute
pain there now throughout the rest of
this video we're gonna be getting into
that juicy detail first one is gonna be
about mallow on take down but
essentially it's going to be a
four-player co-op mission essentially
that is at level 50 you don't have to do
this at with four people you could
totally do this solo but it is
definitely recommended that you do with
four people somebody's gonna do this
alone so there's really no point in me
saying that you have to do it or it's
required because there's some guy out
there with the perfect min/max build
that will do so looking from the
gameplay it looks super cool a lot of
different enemies a lot of different
types of enemies different bosses it's
good it's gonna look really insane I'm
noticing a lot of enemies with armor so
a corrosion weapon would really help
there or if you're a most explosive
build that works too of course and the
gameplay might look a little bit off but
that's because the people that were
playing we're not probably used to the
characters that they were playing and
this was preset build so you have to
give him a little bit of slack there
either way the shit's gonna be [ __ ]
insane so definitely be on the lookout
for the Mallo on take down event there's
gonna be new stuff that are probably
that's probably going to be exclusive to
that maybe new weapons new skins and
stuff so I'll definitely be updating you
guys as I find them throughout that
little mission and then lastly we have
the new DLC which has to do with
handsome Jack in its handsome Jack's
Casino we're going to be raiding
handsome Jack's casino for all of his
money and his loot essentially for the
story perspective is that when Moxie and
Jack were married Jack had actually
stolen the idea for the casino and she
wants to steal it back you'll see
throughout the gameplay in the trailer
that I'm showing that even one of the
bars actually says foxy so it's clearly
a play on words of Moxie's bar and
that's why she's extremely pissed about
it so there's gonna be new skins new
enemies new NPCs new weapons new
anything like weapons shields mods
grenades exclusive stuff all to this DLC
that's coming and they've they mentioned
how it's going to roughly be about seven
to eight hours I mean a few speeder on
this could be four to five so
if you pick a good day to play this game
you could easily probably finish this in
one day if even if you take your time as
they were saying it's going to be
releasing on December 19th and it's
scales to whatever whatever level you
are so if you have an endgame character
you get started at 50 or if you're just
getting on sanctuary you could start it
from there as soon as you hit sanctuary
and that one character you could start
the thing immediately so you could be
like level 5 level 6 and get right to it
immediately also something that no one
really talked about in chat but Randy
Pitchford kind of teased here he was
talking about how this is handsome Jax
casino and he was talking about how they
were trying to develop new characters
and kind of give a lot of life to the
old characters because obviously
handsome Jack had died in Borderlands 2
but because of them you know kind of
going all out with this dlc they had the
option to of course use Jack just maybe
one or two more times to have a little
bit of fun kind of reminisce with the
character even though he had died
because you know they're using his
hologram for the casino but they
mentioned that Jack's doppelganger
Timothy from the pre-sequel
is actually going to make an appearance
I don't know why nobody ever really like
was freaking out about that but me
personally I love Jack's doppelganger
and I can't wait to see where the [ __ ]
Timothy is because after pre-sequel that
man dipped out and I I just want to know
what he's doing here like I said there's
gonna be exclusive loot there's gonna be
a flame Vlad off RPG Cora corrosion
toward pistol Dahl flame SMG probably a
bunch of different elements with those
specific weapons too but that's what
they just showed on screen
and of course these weapons are gonna
have specific effects too we'll have to
see what they look like in game when we
drop them so don't worry once I find
these weapon they're gonna be showing
off all of these as I get them to drop
throughout the game it's gonna be super
crazy like I said they're gonna have
guns grenade shields mods everything
emotes skins this is gonna be a whole
new thing it's gonna be really sick if
you do have the season pass stuff we go
pick this up if you have the season pass
of course just get ready to play the
game but if you don't what are you doing
you got to grab the season pass for this
game it's definitely a worthy purchase
and since its ipiria nan Jack the loader
bots will be coming back in all
different types of forms so depending on
how you feel about that that could be
either really cool or really bad and
that was really about it for the video
and what was happening the only other
thing that they mentioned was a little
bit of fan questions and one thing that
Randy Pitchford had stated which he
talked about months ago
that they didn't really plan on doing
about new vault hunters because even
though they had released new vault
hunters and maybe you enjoyed them like
for example I loved Krieg you know DLC
fall hunter and Borderlands 2 Creed was
the best character that they had
released not many people had played the
new characters everyone kind of just got
their main character and really didn't
stop playing you know there was those
people that picked up accident for the
first time and just stuck with him for
five six years for some reason no one
really switched so that's why they
didn't decide to do vault hunters but it
seems like they're planning on expanding
the character maybe through story
elements skills new skill trees it
sounds really sick and I actually can't
wait I'm totally cool with the
alternative of getting multiple
different skill trees for the same
character it allows for different builds
different elements and I think it's
gonna be really sick just let me know
what you guys think about that in the
comments below
hey guys let me know what you guys think
about this stuff in the comments below I
don't remember what the release date for
the Mallo on take down Venice I do
believe it's tomorrow but I also could
be totally wrong I'll have to
double-check my sources and stuff to
confirm that but from what we do know is
that DLC one is coming out December 19th
so definitely you know save up time you
know if you're in school you'll probably
be out of school by then for break and
definitely get ready to play some
borderlines 3 there's always like to me
if you enjoy guys subscribe if you're
new and peace out guys I'll see you in
the next couple videos good bye
you